these two are back in court again in a
he said she said battle with 50 million
dollars at stake
she goes yeah he threw a phone at me and
hit me and i'm going where
i don't see a cut a bruise swelling
redness
that's amber diligently taking notes
today and smirking as johnny listened
intently to their former friend and
neighbor brought to tears defending him
it's not right what ha what she did and
what happened
for so many people to get
affected
it's insane
johnny beat me up really good this time
yesterday both exes appeared emotional
as the jury heard amber's graphic claims
he ends up assaulting her and sexually
assaults her the first witness johnny's
sister christie she booked the couple's
travel and told the court she would
reserve an extra hotel room for johnny
to escape when he and amber fought depp
looked solemn as she also testified
about their abusive mother explaining
that amber often triggered johnny she
called him an old fat man
amber's attorney repeatedly mentioned
depp's alleged substance abuse issues
showing text messages stop drinking stop
coke or stop pills you wrote those words
to mr deb right
i wrote those words
and he brought up johnny's friendship
and matching tattoos with another star
who denies his ex's abuse claims you'll
hear evidence of drug binges with his
good friend marilyn manson
he was hitting me
hard and repeatedly
johnny says amber's 2018 op-ed calling
herself a domestic violence victim
damaged his career the pirates of the
caribbean star claims he was dropped
from the fifth sequel after the op-ed
was published he was also let go from
the fantastic beasts franchise do not
fight out of hatred
johnny had actually only done a day's
filming i think on his own depp whose
films grossed more than 10 billion
across two decades testified in 2020
that he was 100 million dollars in debt
both exes are set to take the stand this
portrayal is a lie and she has been
preparing to give the performance of her
life in this trial
[Music]
you